Does looking around
the animal kingdom
make you wonder if your
penis is the same as all
these other animals?
I mean, if you have one?
It probably doesn't.
But just in case, we've gathered
up some of the weirdest ones.
Hey gang, Trace here for DNews.
Sex organs are weird looking.
But they're also crazy cool.
We gathered up the
strangest animal penises
we could think of.
Their 16-inch-long member makes
the ducks more competitive
sexually and also helps
lasso potential mates
who are trying to escape.
Just note, this thing is
longer than the duck is tall.
These little guys are
really promiscuous.
And the tip is all brushy to
wipe off other duck's sperm.
And the base of the super-long
corkscrew-like like penis
is barbed.
I'm not sure why,
but it's weird.
The barnacle, winner
for most giant.
It's not always
size that matters.
But if it did,
the lowly barnacle
would win the
locker room debate.
Barnacles have the largest
penis of any animal-- relatively
speaking.
As a sidebar to the
giantness, the barnacle
is anchored in place.
So it can't exactly
go off and copulate.
Instead, it releases
sperm into the water
and lets the current carry it to
a female to fertilize the eggs.
That's really strange.
To sea slug doesn't ever
need a prophylactic.
Instead, once it's done, it
just throws the penis away.
Yep, just falls off
there, and the dude
grows a knew one
to use tomorrow.
And after it mates, one third
of the penis sort of just
dangles and falls
off and floats away.
I'm not joking.
The penis slowly
regrows, but the slug
can use what's left to
copulate again and again.
It has a disposable penis.
And finally, the winner
of the penis-off-- this
is the leopard slug.
And when it wants to mate, it
adds an ingredient to its mucus
trail that changes flavor.
When an interested
mate comes along,
the couple find a spot to
hang from a mucus strand,
and then push their
penises, yes, they
both have penises, out
the side of their head.
Yes, they live
behind their heads.
And they intertwine
the things and it's--
What surprises you about
the animal kingdom?
Not necessarily a
penis, but something
cool an animal can do.
Share it in the comments
area and let us now.
Thanks for tuning in to DNews.
We really appreciate
you watching.
See you later.